hey everyone how's it going welcome back
to my JavaScript crash course for
beginners series what I'm going to talk
about today is data types specifically
what I'll cover is what a data type is
what data types are available in
JavaScript and how each one is typically
used and of course as always we'll go
over a whole bunch of examples to make
sure your understanding is rock-solid
now in the last episode we talked in
depth about variables what they are how
they're declared and some of the best
practices surrounding them it was
natural to start with that before moving
on to data types since you need to know
how to declare variables before moving
on to knowing what types of variables
can even exist in JavaScript now I've
already got everything set up as before
I have my environment set up here and
ready to use
I'm gonna go launch my Python server so
let's just go and do that here we've got
the Python server running on the left
side of the screen and I've got a dime
open here so you can see I've got the
editor let's make it a bit more visible
on the right I've got chrome let's just
go and open the developer tools more
tools developer tools we're gonna stay
on the console and we'll just go to
navigate to localhost now we've loaded
the project files and whenever we reload
it'll show let's get started if you
recall from the last video you declare a
variable in JavaScript using one of
three keywords let constand var what
Const far although as I mentioned using
bar is considered bad form these days so
we'll only talk about using lead and
Const I will go into much more depth at
a later date on the difference between
let constant var and Y many experts
disapprove of using var now that Latin
Const are available but we do have to
save that for a later date and build up
more experience and background first
let's declare a variable here let's go
with something simple
let first and let's deconstruct what's
happening here first we're declaring to
JavaScript that we want a variable and
we use the let keyword then we're
telling javascript the name of that
variable its first variable and finally
we're assigning a value which is 1 let's
compare this to a second variable again
we declared a javascript that we want a
variable by using the let keyword we
give it a name second variable and we
assign it a value in this case the
sentence hello how are you now the
difference between these two variables
is of the first one held a number and
the second one held a complete sentence
or in programming terms a string this is
an example of the different data types
that are available in javascript in fact
there are eight different data types and
total in JavaScript as of December 2019
that's eight not five or six or seven or
whatever other videos have said I've
actually not seen one that got it right
so far there are eight and you don't
need to believe me I'm I'm not the
authority here I'm just some Rando with
a youtube channel but if you look on
Mozilla site they are a bit of an
authority on JavaScript and they do say
here the latest ECMO script standard
defines eight data types now those of
you who are unfamiliar who with whom
Mozilla is they are the developer of
Firefox so they do know JavaScript in
and out so that is eight different data
types there are seven primitives and
then there's object which is a bit of a
special one now let's go over each one
starting with string
I'm just going to assign I'm just going
to assign a value this is the string
strings or text like in books and we're
gonna print it out so let's go back to
the console here and reload the page and
this is a string string of text like in
books and we can take a look at the type
of the variable by using type of again
let's just go reload here and you can
see the JavaScript tells you that the
type of string variable is a string as I
mentioned strings are text data they are
what you'd find in books they're full
sentences their names there's there that
kind of thing and they're typically
declared by using quotes so you can
declare them by putting two quotes
together so let's just go here that
string variable 2 equals so you do so
you write two quotes like this and then
you write whatever you want inside
whatever I want to write inside close
you can also declare strings using
single quotes
now one of the things you might notice
here is that when I use the double
quotes I'm allowed to use single quotes
inside the sentence and when I use
single quotes I'm allowed to use double
quotes inside the sentence now it
doesn't matter if you use single quotes
or double quotes to declare your string
but it does affect what kind of quotes
you can use inside the string now if for
whatever reason you need to use both so
you need to use single quotes and double
quotes you have to do what's called
escaping
you can see here that I managed to use
both by putting this slash here and that
is an escape character it means that
we're not going to count this quote
towards the overall string we're just
going to use it in isolation here and
that's the only way that you can use
quotes in a string the next JavaScript
type is number so we'll just declare a
number variable but number variable
equal five I'm going to declare a few of
them because number can represent many
different types of numbers so two and
let's print these out
go in reload you'll see five 3.14159 and
there was number number number they're
all the same to JavaScript their numbers
and the number type in JavaScript is
exactly what you think they are their
numbers they represent positive or
negative numbers and numbers include
decimal places for anybody technical
watching this they're represented
internally by using 64-bit
double-precision floating-point numbers
if you didn't understand that don't
worry just ignore it for now or google
it but it's a bit complex to explain
right now
the gist of it is JavaScript numbers are
what are referred to as real numbers in
mathematics now often you see this given
in tutorials as two different types of
numbers integers and round numbers so
integers are negative 1 2 3 sorry
negative 2 negative 3 and they're a
positive 1 2 or 3 you'll notice that
they don't have any decimal then there's
decimal numbers like five point one zero
point zero zero zero zero three negative
1000 point zero zero nine Accession etc
internally javascript only has a single
representation for numbers and it may or
may not have any decimals javascript
doesn't care whether or not your number
has decimals if it has decibels or not
it's still the same thing to JavaScript
it's a number type there's no
differentiation between an integer
that's something with no decimals and
one with decimals they're not somehow
special or different to JavaScript
they're just two different numbers with
two different values now in more
advanced cases there are some ways of
using numbers with no decimals ie
integers differently but that's really
out of scope in much more advanced
the next type just go ahead big hint let
Big int variable equals 1 2 3 n 1 so log
let's just go and reload that and see
what happens you can see that javascript
identified that we used a big int it
knew because we had an integer value
here and then a special and n at the end
of it these are related to the number
type we just talked about and the big n
stands for big integer and it's a way
for you to tell JavaScript not to use
the standard number representation that
it has so the one that we just talked
about instead why you're asking
javascript to use is a special type that
handles integer values only and
arbitrarily large integer values to boot
energy values being of course positive
and negative numbers with no decimal
points 1 2 3 or negative 1 2 3 now this
is a really special type and you need
some fairly exceptional circumstances to
need to use it I can imagine if you're
writing some specialist scientific or
financial software they use numbers that
you really just can't safely represent
using the number type that we described
earlier you'd use this in that case as a
beginner you're almost certainly not
going to need to use this the next type
is boolean so let's just go William and
we'll declare some boolean variables
and like always we'll just type it or
we'll print the value of them and we'll
also print their type let's just go here
so false true boolean boolean what we
expect
now the boolean you might be familiar
with if you've ever taken boolean logic
and algebra if not don't worry the
takeaway here is that boolean variables
in JavaScript are either true or false
this is often used when you're writing
conditional code ie if statements since
we haven't covered if statements yet I'm
not gonna write a bunch of code
involving them just to show you since
you might not understand it instead what
I'm gonna do it I'm just going to
describe at a high level how you might
use boolean variables generally what
they are as variables that can change
the way the code executes depending on
whether or not your variable is set to
true or false so imagine writing a
program that needs to display either a
login screen or a welcome screen like
one or the other and it depends entirely
on whether or not the user is logged in
now if you have a variable called is
logged in so let's say you have a
variable is logged in so you have a
variable is logged in and if is logged
in is true then display the welcome
screen otherwise if is logged in isn't
true and display the login screen
so typically boolean czar used in
situations like that you want to
conditionally execute one set of code if
something is true otherwise you want to
do something else yeah you also notice
that I use two special keywords here
true and false
over here false
and these are reserved in JavaScript
specifically for boolean z'
let's move on to the next type so the
undefined type just go and run that here
you can see that the value of undefined
variable is undefined and the type of
undefined variable is undefined
undefined is a special type in
JavaScript used to represent the fact
that you haven't assigned a value to a
variable yet you'll notice in the code
that I wrote that I didn't assign this
to anything you can see over here I just
declared undefined variable but I didn't
give it a value and so when we go to
inspect it when we go to look at it and
in the console we just get undefined
it's the default value if you don't set
anything the next type is no it will
declare variable no print it out
javascript has a special type to
represent the absence of something and
that's the null type it literally means
that the variable is set to nothing
typically if something is null it means
that nothing was set and that was
intentional
no was set intentionally this is
slightly different than if something
wasn't set up for example
unintentionally like the programmer made
a mistake and forgot to set a value in
which case it would be set to undefined
it like in the example before but in
this case it's a special way for you to
set something to nothing believe it or
not this is used a lot in programming
let's say that you're writing a game and
the main character has a shield so let's
just go over here and we have a variable
named shield so let field but if the
character has just started the game they
haven't picked up a shield yet so you as
a programmer may intentionally set the
shield variable to no and when they go
and pick it up you'll set this to
something else and when they drop it
you'll set it back to no and it's a
really common pattern it just represents
nothing the next type is symbol so
that's clear a symbol
and this printed out doodoo reload and
you can see the value is symbol and the
type was symbol now symbols are kind of
a funky special type in JavaScript
they're only allowed to be created a
single time and each time you make one
it's completely unique you can make as
many as you want but every time you
declare one it's unique so if you make
two and even if you're trying to make
them the same way if you compare them
the result will be false so let's see an
example of that so I already made one
simple variable one that variable two
equal symbol I would say hello again and
now have you watched this oops
reload and false simple variable one was
not equal to symbol variable two because
as I said every time you create one
they're unique and that's the main
property of symbols they can't ever be
recreated now there's some really super
cool advanced use cases for them but the
takeaway here for anybody new is that
they exist they're a primitive data type
in JavaScript they're a thing and they
have the properties that I described you
most likely won't need to use them in
the near future but it's good to know
they exist last but not least we're
going to go on to object
I'll just declare some objects object
one and we'll write them out and write
the types let's go and reload this now
and you can see one two three named
Homer last name Simpson and both were
objects objects are probably the most
useful data type that we're going to run
into but though they'll need a full
follow up we have the object type the
object type in JavaScript is a
general-purpose container you can think
of them as collections of data in the
examples I provided the first one was a
list of numbers over here so we've got
this list of numbers and the second one
is more like a mega variable with sub
variables so you've got this variable
named object variable and it has a name
and last name you could kind of think of
it as a bundle of variables all together
now I'd like to go into much more detail
on object specifically in the follow up
video but to takeaway here is that they
represent collections of data so you
kind of bundle up a bunch of variables
together into one super variable now
those variables could be primitives like
numbers strings they can also be other
objects so you could have an object that
contains other objects it doesn't really
matter and the reason that you're doing
this is imagine you had an object called
person and that contained related data
including their name their age their
date of birth favorite color it's a lot
easier to have a single variable or you
can refer to each of those sub variables
instead of having a dozen loose
variables sitting in your code
and when you pass it around and when you
use it you can refer to a single
variable it just makes your code a lot
neater and tidier and easier to read and
easier to reason about if that didn't
make a huge amount of sense don't worry
objects are a big topic all on their own
and one that I plan to tackle soon so
look for a long and in-depth video from
them on me if you have any questions or
concerns let me know in the comments
below let me know if I move too quickly
on something or didn't go into enough
depth on something that about wraps up
this video in the series stay tuned for
the next video on my JavaScript crash
course series I plan to talk about
functions but I hope you enjoyed this
and see you soon
Cheers